you very rarely see this and it's going
to get a lot worse this is the border
fence between Mexico and the United
States migrants from the newly arriving
caravans in Tijuana scaling the steel
railings they're inches away from
America and San Diego in the distance in
truth if they jump they'll be caught in
seconds unless of course hundreds do so
at the same time and that's a fact the
u.s. Border Patrol watching in cars and
on horseback and quad bike are fully
aware of the sounds of patrolling
helicopters had never far away anymore
and this is unusual the border fence is
monitored and patrolled every day of the
year of course but the migrant caravans
the rhetoric of President Trump and his
military deployment here has raised the
stakes if America's weary of the
migrants some in Tijuana have firmly
against them a crowd attempted to
demonstrate against the caravan members
outside their camp in a Sports Complex
they were prevented by rows of police
and they simply couldn't get down the
street face to face they accuse the
police of protecting the wrong people
the mayor of Tijuana has echoed the
United States president and saying that
he wants to turn them away this is what
the authorities have been worried about
of course this isn't a very big
demonstration but there are a lot more
migrants due to arrive here shortly and
the police are worried about clashes
between those people from to honor who
against migrants coming here the
migrants themselves and of course the
police find them so stuck in the middle
but not everyone is against the migrants
these women is shouting at the
protesters to clear off scuffles break
out the locals say that the caravan is
actually bringing their small shops new
business inside the Sports Complex the
migrants spend a lot of time sleeping
many are exhausted they've travelled
thousands of miles to get here by and
large they wanted claim asylum in the
United States most are escaping endemic
crime and poverty in their Central and
South American countries half are
children some of them are very tiny
indeed Kawana was born on the journey
north
she's a month and seventeen days old the
mother Belinda and dad Juan are escaping
the El Salvadoran gang ms-13 we want to
kill the couple for informing on a
gangster that gang member is or Linda's
brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before America - Diaz
don't make the sink I presume
[Music]
the movement of people heading north to
the United States has gone on for years
but something new is happening it said
more convoys are forming thousands
already in Mexico will arrive here soon
there is no way that Mexico can cope
this is difficult at the moment but very
shortly
this could turned into a full-scale
humanitarian crisis still Ram ji skynews
tier-one